So you've decided that you need
more than what can be provided by
all the variance of Roboto.
How do you pick an additional font?
Well, it's pretty hard.
Choosing the right font isn't
only a technical challenge.
It's not enough to just pick
a font that's easy to read and
contrasts well with
the content around it.
Your choice of font can impact
how your users perceive your app.
And how they emotionally respond to it.
Hand written fonts or
fonts with rounded terminals can
make your app feel informal.
On the other hand, very geometric fonts
might give an impression of order and
structure.
And some fonts might even feel robotic.
Weight matters too here.
Light fonts are those
with really thin serafs,
can invoke impressions of elegance,
but also impermanence.
Meanwhile ultra bolds
might evoke heaviness.
But possibly stability, and fonts can
even be associated with a time period.
While some may have an almost
historic significance,
others may be considered
a little too trendy.
There really aren't great absolute rules
for choosing the right custom font for
your app, but here are a couple
of tips that might prove handy.
First, limit your font pallet.
You can often get away with
using just one custom font for
branding areas like your app bar and
Roboto for everything else.
If you do pick another sans
sarif font to replace Roboto for
UI elements like the text here,
make sure to switch over completely.
So you don't have two similar
looking fonts next to each other.
Here Helvetica and
Roboto are placed next to each other.
But since they look kind of similar,
it's kind of this weird uncanny valley.
It's not clear if it's intentional or
not.
Second, try out the font you're thinking
of on a couple of different devices with
varying screen densities.
What looks awesome at xxhdpi
might look really muddy at mdpi.
Notice the serifs on the H
are barely even visible.
And finally, watch out for
unintended cognitive dissonance.
And make sure the font fits
the mood you're setting in the app.
If your product is all about being fast,
putting a font with a heavy weight on
might give the feeling of
a slow lumbering giant.
On the other hand, if you have
an app that's highly technical
an overly decorative font might
not only be distracting but
might erode your user's trust
in what you're trying to do.
So does your proposed extra custom
font meet all those requirements?
Great.
James is going to walk you through
how to use the font you just
picked in your app.